[Applause]
and finally new rule before we tackle
any of our daunting specific problems
here in america we have to figure out
how a country can solve any problem if
so many of its people are so intractably
astoundingly mind-numbingly stupid
and i'm not saying that as hyperbole or
just out of frustration i mean this
country just might be empirically
verifiably too [ __ ] dumb to continue
as an ongoing enterprise
[Music]
jay leno used to do a classic bit called
jaywalking where he asked ordinary
citizens the kind of question we used to
consider common knowledge and in the
internet age that bit has been
shall we say updated
and is still a useful indicator of where
exactly we are on the bird brain chart
take a look at some of the answers given
on a tick tock site called project
better who is the first person to land
on the sun
lance armstrong
what is the biggest city in the world uh
i think it's like
like asia what is the biggest city in
the world
europe if you were born in 2021 how old
would you be
21. what country is venice italy located
in for a hundred dollars you have any
clue oh gosh i'm going to be a teacher
so i should know this um you should
paris
where is queen elizabeth from
egypt egypt
where is it brazil
so
so you tell me if a country is only as
strong as its people what can the future
possibly hold for a population this
moronic
being a full-grown adult and thinking a
human could walk on the sun
or that the biggest city in the world
was asia
when plainly it's europe
[Laughter]
this country simply has no education
standards anymore they will let you out
of a public high school and give you a
diploma and you don't have to actually
know anything
which used to be the mission of schools
knowing things
i know it's super important to stop the
grooming of our kids or i don't know to
start it and and certainly critical race
theory must be stricken from the
curriculum or who knows maybe included
in all of it but you know while we're
having those fights could someone please
notice that the kids don't actually know
anything
as i travel this country on weekends
doing stand-up now i see the political
ads that are running on the local tv
markets and
i think how can this possibly work on
people
and then i remember oh yes they think
queen elizabeth is from egypt
[Applause]
when again plainly it's brazil
political campaigns used to turn out two
kinds of ads the positive or what i like
to call the village people ad
where you're seen with a cop a
construction worker
a military guy and a minority
and then the negative ads the ones that
look like they were shot by navy seals
wearing night-vision goggles
will you make your opponent look like
someone who killed their spouse on an
episode of datebot
but now it seems they figured out that
the people are dumb enough that you can
put the positive and the negative in the
same ad here's one we see in la a
hundred times a day for congressperson
young kim
eight times in a row politician greg
raths increased our tax rates and fees
just like biden and the liberals wraths
makes california unaffordable greg raths
even proposed raising his taxpayer
salary over 60 percent we pay more he
makes more that's politician greg ratz
but young kim is fighting wraths in the
liberals
[Applause]
that's right i'm young
and unlike my opponent i'm in color
come on don't want don't you want your
representative to be in color
as opposed to an x-ray
and i don't chew on cigars or stuff cash
in my pockets or get
drunk with washington insiders and jail
cell doors never shut behind me
when candidates and political ads say i
approve this message they should have to
add at the end you dumb [ __ ]
i'm brad turnbull and i approve this
message you dumb [ __ ]
candidates always say they're just
highlighting the differences between
them and their opponents here's
congressman mark moore's ad highlighting
the difference between him and opponent
melanie stansberry
murderers rapists and childbusters
walking free we need to pass the breathe
act in congress stop the madness stop
melanie stansberry
what the hell melanie stansberry why are
you so pro-rapist in child molester
don't you know that voters see child
molesters unfavorably
voters want someone who will let them
know i'm the good guy because i'm
meeting with firemen i'm meeting with
teachers i'm meeting with cops i'm
talking to kids i'm talking to black kid
i'm wearing a hard hat and looking
concerned
i'm pointing to the border wall with my
thumb
[Laughter]
come on that's my thumb you must know i
got this
[Applause]
after all didn't you hear me say i'm
strong on values and good for jobs that
i'm
fighting for you and on your side and
i'm going to get things done and shake
things up and then i have a plan details
to follow
to clean things up my god my sleeves are
rolled up what more evidence do you need
on the good god
unlike my opponent who's always cackling
maniacally and
who lives in washington
good guys live in america which is great
in pure bad guys live in washington
gross
they're always career politicians
career politician career politician
career politician career politicians
career politicians career politician
career politician
yeah career politician
good guys don't even go to washington
but they will if they have to like mike
garcia
it won't be easy on my family but it's
something we'll go through together
i just hope they don't get killed by
melanie stansberry
and you know i'm not
i'm not picking on mike or young king or
any of them in particular because
they're all alike well wait not all
there are actually some ads that are
even more submental
and in 2022 i'm going to blow away the
democrat socialist agenda
yeah
here's three words no one ever has to
say to marjorie taylor greene dumb it
down
there is an entire species of political
ads on the right where the candidate
just shoots something they don't like
a lot of these ads make no mention of
policy at all it's just truck
gun
me like these things you like vote me
but
but here's something i notice that's
different about the ads that
conservatives make versus the ones from
liberals the conservatives wear that
description like it's their first name
they cannot say it enough
i'm a conservative outsider america's
most conservative top rated conservative
a real conservative proven conservative
christian conservative america first
conservative conservative warrior i'm so
conservative
but you never hear anyone bragging about
being a liberal
there's no liberal bob schmohawk is a
liberal who wants to enact more liberal
policies
democrats might want to think about what
that means
because the implication is you're
embarrassed by what liberalism has
become that the term is now irredeemably
coupled with woke nonsense
which is a shame because despite their
nonsense
it's still generally
generally a better product
but what does it say about your brand if
you don't want to say what you are so
much a liberal politics nowadays is
identity politics and yet it seems we
found the one thing liberals won't
identify as liberals
you